ich möchte waren fotos sprechen von
dieser woche da sehen wir auf einem bild
bleibt mir putin wir sind hanni und wir
sehen erdogan im hand in hand
wenn sie so ein bisschen spüren sie da
ekeln
weiß nicht ob gefühle der beste maßstab
für nationale politische entscheidungen
sind was deutlich macht ist wie wichtig
derjenigen ist die gemeinsam wie wir an
die internationalen regeln nicht nur
glauben sondern für sie eintreten dass
wir mit werte partnern zusammen stehen
weil es gibt andere akteure die nicht
für unsere werte einstehen und die
verbünden sich im zweifel auch dass der
türkische präsident mit auf diesem foto
ist das ist eine herausforderung um es
mal freundlich zu sagen weil die türkei
ja gerade mit blick auf die ukraine sind
dadurch den computern der massiven
unterstützung im militärischen bereich
leistet auch jetzt mit blick auf die
betreiber
lieferung und deswegen ist mir dieses
foto mehr als unverständlich gerade aus
sicht eines nato mitglied sie haben zu
beginn das kinderkriegen ist gesagt dass
die sanktionen gegen russland die
wirtschaft ruinieren bleibt mit diesem
satz glauben sie immer noch dass die
sanktionen wie sie jetzt sind die
russische wirtschaft ruinieren wird auf
mittel und langfristige sicht ist der
ganze krieg den der russische präsident
führt auch gegen sein eigenes volk
gerichtet fall in einer situation wo die
kriegsführung über allem und jedem steht
auch seine eigene wirtschaft seine
eigene bevölkerung zu opfern und die
sanktionen die ja nur eine reaktion sind
auf diesen diesen russischen krieg
führen dazu bei dass die
wirtschaftskraft von russland natürlich
massiv eingeschränkt wird also die
verantwortung für die ruine des des
russischen landes der russischen
volkswirtschaft die trägt der russische
präsident aber mit brutalen angriffs
aber gar nicht mit putin argumentiert ja
dass die sanktionen in weniger treffen
als wohnungs und es gibt ja auch immer
mehr in deutschland die das versuchen zu
argumentieren und sagen die sanktionen
wie gerade sind die treffen uns mehr als
nur
kurzfristig ist das sicherlich so dass
wir große herausforderungen haben aber
wenn man sich anschaut was in russland
los ist muss man sich halt wir
gegenwärtigen das ist ja kein normales
system das ist eine autokratie und das
ist keine demokratie in jedem normalen
land was auf demokratischen füßen steht
müssen natürlich jeder präsident er
jeder bundeskanzler ministerpräsident
sofort zurücktreten wenn die spitze des
landes das land wäre es wenn wir
inflationsraten haben denn große teile
von internationalen konzern nicht mehr
agieren würde ich meine das alles reale
auswirkungen in russland die treffen
natürlich russland 1000 mal mehr als das
was wir eine herausforderung
wirtschaftlich haben wir haben doch
nicht die zahlen hier bei uns in
deutschland wie in russland die sache
ist nur die in russland ist es so dass
jeder der das zur sprache bringt
entweder im gefängnis landet oder das
land verlassen muss weil keine kritische
stimme mehr hörbar ist und deswegen ist
die situation so dass die reaktion des
landes eine andere ist weniger hart als
es wäre wenn all die auswirkungen bei
uns sichtbar werden lassen uns über die
situation an der front in der ukraine
sprechen ich habe ich noch ein satz
wieder sagen zu sagen weil er mir
wichtig ist weil viele zu recht auch auf
meiner tour durch deutschland mache
fragen ja aber die sanktionen die
verhindern ja den krieg gar nicht das
stimmt in die sanktionen waren auch nie
so dass wir uns überlegt haben wenn wir
russische energieimporte reduzieren das
am morgen der krieg vorbei ist das habe
ich auch zurückgehen der song zu noch
immer wieder versucht gegenüber der
ukrainischen regierung deutlich zu
machen diese sven ostritz weinig kommt
wenn nur öl embargo endlich kommt dann
ist der krieg vorbei weil es vollkommen
klar war ein präsident der sein eigenes
land bereit ist zu opfern der wird sich
auch von wirtschaftssanktionen nicht
abbringen lassen aber dass mir wichtig
wir verteidigen hier die internationale
regeln und ihre internationale ordnung
und wenn wir dann sagen wir ergreifen zu
recht nicht militärisch ein aber wir es
hat auch keine ökonomischen folgen
würden wir das akzeptieren dass wir in
etwa so wenn wir in deutschland stets 15
jahre auf mord das verhindert nicht dass
nicht auch
ein mord passiert und niemand in
deutschland würde auf die idee kommen zu
sagen diese strafe bringt es jetzt ja
nicht wir schaffen weil die strafen ab
sondern es ist ein signal an die
gesellschaft wir akzeptieren diesen
massivsten regelbruch nicht so wie wir
als internationale gesellschaft als
internationale ordnung sagen wir
akzeptieren nicht wenn ein land und dann
noch ein land was ständiges mitglied im
sicherheitsrat ist die die regeln der
vereinten nationen so brutal bricht